from italy
we got one d4
okay let's see go for
the delayed slav
go for the a6 variation
what you're supposed to do against
knight bd2
the answer is i don't know
um
this b2 seems a bit soft i'll go e6
knight h4
i thought was the point there
now yeah this is still
not stupid for white but at least i'm
getting bishop
e4 here and i'm not sure
if the bishop belongs in e2 in these
lines i think it would be
more active and probably also better
place than
d3 now opening
the h file my opponent has to be a bit
careful
of some bishop d6 coming
okay i see the point is knight f3 after
bishop t6
so then we'll go c5 instead
might seem a bit weird opening up the
position while my
king is still in the center but i think
it's not really a problem
knight b3 is tricky knight f3 seemed
more
logical because of um
the knight seems more active but i think
my opponent didn't want to allow cd5
cd4 queen d4 then bishop c5 attacking
the queen
though g7 may have been hanging there
then
um but my opponent feels that denying
the c5 square for the bishop is very
important
and in general this was all not
completely necessary but i
still should be fine here
because now e4 is fairly logical dc5 as
well of course
pushback 3 i think coming
[Music]
yes push b7 we just developed
[Music]
and we're trying to claim that
the white bishop pair is not that useful
in that yeah because he has a weakness
on
on e3 and also the bishop on c1 does not
look great at the moment
e4 is not good here for wide because
knight b4 comes and
uh my pieces will be really active also
i think b3 is not a great move bishop f6
bishop cannot be developed to to b2 or
a3
because department e3 is hanging and
taking on d5
first would be a major positional
concession
so my opponent instead goes for rook to
e1
this all seems quite dubious to me
knight b4 how about that
knight
knight coming to d3 very soon
bishop b57 would have been possible but
i don't think it
was very good let me see are there
really no tactics here
okay we'll go queen b6 don't want to
exchange quite yet
okay so if brooke well well i thought
maybe he'll go bishop c3 there but then
at least i had knight a4
now rook fda at the point is pushed by
one
not a four e4 do i have any
good knight moves probably not so i'll
just take the bishop although that is a
little bit sad
considering that that was not a great
bishop
my opponent is fighting well somehow
i feel like i should have gotten more
out of this
but i still have some advantage
my opponent is thinking which is a good
thing
g4 we go g5
we're happy happy to see that
um we got g6 preparing e5
possibly
[Music]
rook c2 i think we can take an e3
oh maybe i could not
i got tricked worked before the screen
d4
damn it and we have to play fast
really fast it's disconnecting
that's no good oh my god
[Music]
this is the way i'm gonna win i mean my
position is still good
after bc bishop d4 and so on
um yeah that was unfortunate
really unfortunate i think i would have
won the game but it would have been a
would have been a close fight
okay people